When Jeni Stepien walked down the aisle this weekend in Swissvale, Pennsylvania,...
"It has been the best day of my life."
...the man whose arm she held was not her father.
That would not have been possible because her dad Michael was gone 10 years already,...
...snatched from his little girl's life in a murder.
So, who was this person walking by her side?
On your right you're gonna see a parking lot, my aunt's wearing white pants and...
A person she would not even meet until the day before the wedding,...
...when she had to talk him through the route to the church.
Well, ten years ago, Arthur Thomas was in urgent need of a new heart.
I was on death's door.
And the heart they gave him was Michael's, Jenny's dad's.
Jenny grew up knowing a living part of her father was out there.
We've been talking to him and writing letters and calling.
But it was all long distance until...
Jenny wrote me a letter...
...and she said, "If you're willing, would you walk me down the aisle?"
Thank you so much for coming.
Are you kidding?
And so, there they were in the moment of their meeting,...
...Jenny closer to her dad's beating heart than she had been in years.
So close, she reached to feel that beat.
And on this, her wedding day, that was possible.
John Donvan, ABC News.